como este pueblo muchos se convirtieron
en ríos en pakistán las inundaciones sin
presentes siguen forzando a miles de
personas a huir de sus casas y
enfrentarse a instalaciones deplorables
en condiciones de hacinamiento hacia el
área nos salvamos de morir ahogados en
las inundaciones pero nuestra casa se
derrumbó escapamos pero no pudimos
salvar nuestros bienes bell con la alga
tengamos aquí en un estado terrible
algunas buenas personas de aquí nos
dieron refugio ahora estamos recibiendo
algo de ayuda del gobierno pero sólo
suficiente para llenar nuestros
estómagos ahora es la organización de
naciones unidas alerta que estas
condiciones precarias ponen
especialmente en riesgo la vida de los
niños por la propagación de enfermedades
transmitidas a través del agua de las
1200 personas que fallecieron más de 400
serán menores el sábado el gobierno
paquistaní advirtió nuevamente la
urgencia de la situación es que el off
de base station es va a ser la escala de
la devastación es masiva y requiere una
inmensa respuesta humanitaria para 33
millones de personas
por ello hago un llamamiento a mis
compatriotas a los paquistaníes
expatriados y a la comunidad
internacional para que ayuden a pakistán
en esta hora de necesidad
funcionarios y expertos achacan el nivel
inusual de lluvias monzónicas en
pakistán al cambio climático entre ellos
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres que instó al mundo a dejar de
caminar durmiendo en esta crisis
guterres recorrerá las zonas afectadas
por las inundaciones en pakistán el
próximo 9 de septiembre